we were in the middle of a training
exercise this morning and sunny here ate
about two and a half pounds of c-4
plastique explosive
this dog moves too suddenly he's gonna
go up like Nagasaki
so hopefully pretty soon the c-4 will
mix with the man which is I've been
feeding with him all morning and nature
will run its course and I will be able
to retrieve you can do it he gets the
point you got is belly belly belly no
back off no no no no no no no you're not
going on that's a little different
please don't hump the nice officer come
on right here
yeah mission accomplished yeah you know
that's 90% of law enforcement it's just
perseverance stick to the task
you